5 and 11 two characters from different
shows that
may have more in common than just their
numbers for names
when you take a closer look at
characters across tv and movies
you find that some of them are more
alike than not
from heroes to villains which characters
are one in the same
wanda maximoff and jean grey are two of
the most powerful characters in the
marvel universe
they're both connected to dark forces
that are prophesized to bring
destruction and danger to the earth the
scarlet witch and phoenix force
respectively
and their incredible powers get
intensified through emotions
like from the loss of a loved one you
didn't see that coming
plus there's no denying the similarities
between their true forms it's your
destiny to destroy
the world the trailer for the upcoming
live-action cruella film got a lot of
people talking
you may have noticed some similarities
between emma stone's cruella
and margot robbie's harley quinn both
characters make bold statements with
their fashion
with striking colors that contrast those
around them they have twisted
chaotic evil energy that makes both of
them a villainous force to be reckoned
with
we can't wait to see more of these
characters in their upcoming
movies a dragon
and an ice queen may seem like an odd
comparison at first
but once you take a closer look there's
no denying the likeness
i mean just look at their appearances
blue white and purple colors that make
them look like magic twins
not to mention their water-based powers
that allow them to manipulate water and
run on water pads
also elsa is the fifth element in her
movie while sisu
is the fifth dragon in hers coincidence
i'm not like the the best dragon
the boys who lived harry and luke are
eerily similar characters
chosen ones meant to bring balance to
their world check
wise old mentors that make a sacrifice
for them got it
magical and futuristic weapons unique to
their kind
absolutely these characters also share
strong connections to the big baddie
which makes them enemy number one and
the powerful connection they have to a
magical force is not to be forgotten
i'll never turn to the dark side when it
comes to the burden of power and living
a double life
no two superhero characters embody that
more than peter parker and clark ken
the bad guys are always after their
loved ones and our heroes are constantly
saving them
whether it's lois lane or mj and when
they're not sporting a red and blue
costume
they are nerdy unassuming journalists
peter as a photographer for the daily
bugle and clark as a reporter for the
daily planet
living a double life isn't easy and
these two are constantly being reminded
of
uncle ben's famous words
with a unique set of powers 5 and 11
share more similarities beyond their
number names
5 can jump through time while 11 jumps
through dimensions
both are extremely powerful from a young
age and don't respond too kindly to
authority
and their love for snacks is
unparalleled we can't help but think
what it would be like if these
characters ever met each other
they would surely have a lot to talk
about that's the answer
pale and disfigured super villain anyone
these antagonists weren't always that
way
a troubled childhood and the allure of
immortality is what brought both of
these characters to the dark side
and their direct connection to the
protagonist has them relentlessly making
life hell
for our heroes both these villains have
a hand in killing the old
wise mentor to our heroes who were once
a mentor to them
and once they turn evil they command a
devouted army of loyal followers
with their plan being to take over as
ruthless dictators
you definitely wouldn't want to mess
with these two
harry potter is dead
we all love these billionaire super
geniuses that dress up and fight crime
with their array of gadgets
both these characters have no natural
superpowers instead relying on their wit
tech and combat abilities they have
famous parents who are no longer around
and were both betrayed by their mentor
evil groups are a big problem for these
characters
as batman has ties with the league of
shadows and iron man with the 10 rings
luckily they each have a trusty
assistant to help them out
i don't deserve you often no sir you
don't
captain america and wonder woman are the
star-spangled heroes that represent the
good in humanity
they both don costumes with red and blue
color schemes
and of course they both wield shields
they each fought in a world war and had
a ragtag team of soldiers with them as
backup
even more both these characters lost
their loves during the war
and in each case a sacrifice involving a
plane was the cause
these are extremely smart and
sharp-witted characters who are the
voice of reason for their superhero
groups
every time someone tries to win a war
before it starts innocent people die
raya and the last dragon is a welcome
addition to the disney family
proving that mulan isn't the only one
that can kick butt with the sword
their fierceness and selflessness make
these two of the strongest disney
characters
what they do they do for others namely
their fathers
mulan steps up to take her father's
place in the military while raya goes on
a journey to bring her father back to
life
the strong bonds they have with their
fathers is what drives them forward
and they don't let any obstacles get in
their way also
we have to mention that they both have a
fun dragon as a sidekick
drag gun not lizard i don't do that
tongue thing
a disney princess can't ask for a better
wingman than lumiere or sebastian
these two are the fun lovable right hand
man to their princess
supporting them through and through
finding love isn't easy
but these two make sure the princess
meets her prince whether through a
lovely song
or the perfect mood lighting and of
course who can forget the incredibly
catchy tunes
be our guest and under the sea these two
never fail
to make the moment
don't we all wish we had a gandalf or
obi-wan in our lives
a wise old mentor donning a robe and
yielding a sword who's connected with a
magical force
that can help us along in our journey to
restore balance to the world
yeah that would be awesome especially
given that these two mentors were
willing to sacrifice themselves to help
the hero
these are definitely the best mentors
one can ask for
just don't betray them like their
friends did you were my brother
the two speedsters of marvel and dc
respectively
flash and quicksilver will always be
mentioned together when it comes to
superheroes with super speed
they are both loners who don't have much
outside of family
until they're recruited by a team and
they're incredibly witty
always injecting a well-needed dose of
humor to whatever scene they're in
these speedsters just keep going and
going
i need friends shrek and carl
fredrickson
surprisingly yes when you look at their
personalities and stories
they're actually very similar they're
grumpy lonely men who just want to be
left alone
but people keep invading their land they
have a funny sidekick friend who is
forced upon them
and drags them on an adventure and while
they find this friend
annoying at first they come to enjoy
their company by the end of the story
learning to love others the only
question we have is what would it be
like if these characters ever met each
other
this is my swamp the clown prince of
crime and the split personality of
norman osborne are two of the most
menacing villains in comics they are
crazy
unstable and just all around psychotic
you can never predict what they may do
as they always keep our heroes on their
toes they get their joy from torturing
and taunting the protagonists
their family and friends whether it's
mary jane or rachel dawes
no one is safe from these two and
they're creepy smiling
with new characters being introduced to
our screens every day
it's no surprise some of them share
similarities
now when we watch these shows and movies
we'll always think of their counterparts
which characters do you think are alike